we've got a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine to david p and i
punched my mic because i'm just so
excited about today's voicemail there's
a conversation now developing around
this sjw thing that some say is
pervading the left like a virus here's
another voicemail about it take a listen
why do you say that social justice
warriors is a small fringe of the left
they seem to be all over TV the internet
college campuses everywhere and why is
it that the only people you think are
criticizing them are the alt-right a lot
of these people that are criticizing
them are also people who are on the left
as well like me are worried that their
constant talking about certain words is
be valuing their meaning and a hurting
society as a whole I mean come on how
can you just deny that I am a harsh
critic of extreme political correctness
language policing safe spaces and a lot
of this other stuff that takes place
it's just not the biggest issue or even
close to it so yeah I know that there
are people on the Left who also
criticize so-called sjws or at least
some of the destructive elements of what
those so-called sjw's do I'm one of
those people but it's not the biggest
problem
or even a major problem right now it is
a problem that is compartmentalized
within areas of the left but the big
picture is it's not that big of an issue
it's yeah not I'd like to see polling on
this though like what portion of people
on the Left are social justice warriors
I don't know if that's been done before
it's an easy deal it's a losing poll
because as it is at the term has already
become an ad hominem it's like polling
the left and saying how many of you are
regressive liberals right who's gonna
self-identify that way right I mean it
just it's it's gotten so disconnected
from reality that it barely even makes
any coherent sense and that's how you
end up with voicemails like this one and
I think the caller is right in that they
are very vocal and you see them on call
you see them on TV but you have to
recognize that's not necessarily
representative of the larger population
of the left no doubt about it no doubt
about it we've got a tremendously good
bonus show for you today I hope you'll
watch you can access it by becoming a
member at david pakman.com slash
membership or by becoming a patron for
at least five bucks a month at
patreon.com forward slash david pakman
show